[Musique]
bonsoir madame bonjour mademoiselle
bonsoir monsieur
ce big bang politique auquel j'aspire et
j'attendais je ne vous le cache pas ce
moment avec un peu d'impatience la
gauche caviar découvre la tête de veau
c'est pas simplement en allant au salon
en déambulant pour regarder en tapant
sur le cul des vaches qu'on défend
l'agriculture mois président de la
république je ferais en sorte que mon
comportement soit à chaque instant
exemplaires
je vous demande de vous arrêter
bah je reste droit dans les bottes et je
ferai mon travail que tous les coquins
soient démasqués jugés condamnés et vidé
est ce qu'un jardinier qui va dans son
jardin action tuyau d'arrosage arrosent
les vieux troncs quand le moment est
venu leur est arrivé moi président de la
république je ne traiterai pas mon
premier liste de collaborateurs mais
vous avez tout à fait raison monsieur le
premier ministre nous sommes en 2013 est
aujourd'hui une ministre ça agit
ça ouvre sa gueule et ça ne démissionne
pas qu'il démissionne c'est le seul
service qu'ils puissent encore rendre à
la république
sur la grande muraille conquiert la
bravitude un homme qui fait kiffer qui
dit une bêtise c'est une bourde une
femme qui dit une bêtise c'est une
gourde board gourde pas tout à fait la
même chose on vous la gîte comme ça là
comme une espèce de madone des
prolétaires avant mauviettes
à chaque fois que les types krivine
melançon ce sont des français d'origine
maghrébine je suis le bruit et la fureur
1 parce que qui a contribué à faire
croire aux français que l'intégralité
des hommes politiques étaient
malhonnêtes c'est vous et c'est vous
parce que vous parce que parce que mais
oui bien sûr marty mais qui à lui seul à
lui c'est lui et moi c'est moi enfin
pardon n'est pas l'université je veux
dire excusez moi à mener merci merci
monsieur le professeur si vous étiez mon
élève vous n'auriez pas fait ça et je
redis ce que j'ai dit hier les français
sont des lions dirigés par des ânes vaut
mieux cinq ans avec jose pas que sept
ans avec jean piat est le septième
journaliste je croyais quand même que
cette information était parvenue jusqu à
vous si vous posez des questions si vous
parlez pour me tran laissez vous parler
pour moi d'aller au cinéma avec les
sondages n'importe quoi est possible par
exemple moi j'ai lu un sondage où le
père noël arrive en première position
l'élection présidentielle un suivi de
près par charlot on rapporte une
histoire abracadabrantesque c'est de la
poudre de perlimpinpin
[Musique]
oui je hais ce n'est au swing des années
mais il faut laisser dans le privé comme
dans le public ceux qui veulent
travailler plus pour gagner plus le
faire par conséquent j'irai au charbon
et vous serez bientôt entre ceux qui ne
veulent rien faire et ceux qui veulent
tout défaire eh bien nous nous allons
bien faire c'est quand même ennuyeux que
dans l'intervalle ou soyez devenu vous
l'homme du passif je n'ai pas de leçon
de courage à recevoir de ceux paltoquet
je voudrais m'élever novembre contre une
sinistre hausse qui tend à décourager
les français je crois à l'inégalité des
races oui bien sûr on la demande
quartier chaud à là où de jeunes
sauvageons brûle la voiture de leurs
voisins regardent
ils sont dans les campagnes dans les
vies je parlais de photos sur les
réseaux sociaux ou bien encore on
aimerait voir les crs sur les pistes de
ski où il assure aussi la sécurité des
gens que la police est là beaucoup de
choses à faire le terme nettoyer au
kärcher qu'en termes qui s'impose
ce vilain frémissement des marines qui
sentent venir et boules puantes et qui
se régalent à l'idée de renifler des
odeurs d'égouts
le sexe
ce qu'il ya de plus profond dans l'homme
dont la femme si c'était du temps de ma
fringante jeunesse j'aurais supposer un
sentiments contrariés je vais ce soir
vous fait vous faire
désirer et aimer la république
s'était mis cible tout entier a déjà
constaté à quel point je vous obsède
dans toute votre expression publique
avec une constance qui appelle quand
même l'admiration je vais fermer ma
porte et que sinon que la contribution
aux branches au prochain congrès du
parti communiste je vais vous proposer
de remplacer l'international par la
chanson de serge lama chic aucune
méprise
pas assez de l'engagement
c'est un peu à l'image de la france
car finalement nous ne reconnaissons ici
une communauté la république
françaises français
allons ayons confiance
au revoir
[Musique]